also ist die wahl eures team namens luke
jetzt ein logisches bekenntnis ja das
wollte drei herzen folgt das was ich am
anfang hatte ich ein halbes jetzt alles
gut
los geht's mit willkommen zu einer neuen
folge minecraft legend mit team wir und
wir sind immer noch auf der jagd nach
dem diamanten auf den euro was wollten
die aufnahme warum also jetzt direkt am
anfang
das darf ich rausnehmen weil er wusste
man hörte sehr laut copyright musik okay
ruft mich in der aufnahme golf verlegt
sich kritischer typ so kommst du zu mir
unter der last lassen und bei mir ist
mein team lobte harald team uk und ich
lerne den kommissar ist dann gib mir
eine stelle ich werde auf alle fälle ein
paar fragen sich die russen folge so zu
nehmen wartete gleich zum thema logik
kann man gleich ansetzen
also ist die wahl eures team namens luke
jetzt ein logisches bekenntnis ja
weniger sachen bis zum eigentlichen
weißt du was ich gefunden habe
redin weißt was gehört gefunden hast du
dich ein holzschwert hingeschmissen
komm mal her von mir ich hab ja etwas
seltsames entdeckt irgendwas irgendwas
selbst ich weil ich kann sich so ein
autopsie von ok oder so ich bin auf dem
weg alles klar dass ich aufpassen
auffassen
ok wartet dann lasse muss die arminia
flutet das mit lama während des abbaus
den ersten zumindest hier oben drauf den
quattro ist okay dann baute ab
oder weil ich muss auch was aus dem
inventar
jetzt fließt das wasser und westlich das
wassernetz politikers ab okay weil die
dame läuft bevor man wo man in die lava
selbst kommt nicht immer so
du kannst du kannst es nämlich alles
abbauen ohne das taktisch was mit denen
passiert dann dann nimm du dein wasser
noch mit uns einfach fünf díaz llanos es
sein alter das wird auch zeit dass wir
matthias finden
denn hier auch überall noch jetzt alles
gerade hier dicht was ja aber noch übrig
ist
er kennt das man erstmal die ganzen hier
abchecken ob man noch irgendwo sichtbare
diaz hat und falls nicht dann gehen wir
einfach weiter mit strippen maniche sah
ich habe aber gerade was gefunden wir
hätten also von anfang an schon runter
direkt zu den dias gehen können wie sie
möchten
weil diese lagerstelle die hier gefunden
habe die habe ich am anfang der letzten
folge habe ich die nämlich schon
gefunden heißt werde einfach nach unten
gefolgt wären direkt zu den die acht
gekommen
ich will dir grad hinterher aber du
spielst mit bleib ich unten vor meiner
spieler dann bewährt und ramadan und ich
mache mir vor allen dingen mal als gut
das ist nur ein kratzer alter der ich
hatte vier herzen und überlaufen alter
mann musste höllisch aufpassen den
nächsten abschnitt geborenen den
nächsten abschnitt aber das
zusammenbleiben komm runter zu mir komm
runter klar ich komme mir darunter ein
bisschen effizienter wenn wir das
zusammen machen da kann's besser
absprechen
auf jeden fall schon batzen gold 19 gold
ja ich mal wieder gehört ich habe auch
schon wieder gold gekommen
noch aber ist wieder krieg explodiert
und das war bei mir das war bei mir
keine sorgen aber wir müssen jetzt
langsam nach oben bei oben sind unsere
essensvorräte noch eingelagert
ja ja okay ist und dann komm doch mal
rüber das erste skript mein kommst du
sehr mich ja vorne bist du okay alles da
dann hier scheinen keine die erste sein
das so und dann fangen wir jetzt einfach
genau hier an stück zu stück mein ok in
die errichtung dann gehe ich ja jetzt
klar ich brauche hier nochmal ein
kraftvolles in watte problem ist wie
viel essen hast du noch noch zwei froh
dass wir die hälfte davon geben ich hab
jetzt noch eins und vier melone die
melonen will ich jetzt nicht unbedingt
verraten ja ich habe auch noch ein
bisschen rohes fleisch verbrennen hier
hast du noch gerne ich aber noch kohle
sieht es immer so fritz ja okay dann
fragen alte wir müssen jetzt wenn wir
uns finden wenn wir uns auf 5 ms finden
heute 14 fucking op dann haben wir
nämlich dann haben wir nämlich das
einzig wahre
ich hab so wie selten schwere tier sind
ein paar fragen aber die sind sehr sehr
sind schon sehr an private gehen die
kannst kannst du ja vorstellen
ok also lokal wie alt bist du wohnst du
auf welche schule gehst du würdest du
schon wurdest du schon mal von fans
angesprochen also schule und wohnort
komme auf jeden fall mal streichen du
kannst du alt bist du
ich bin ich bin 15 das interessierte mal
so viele leute voll krass ich muss sagen
ich nehme an meinem team per ich ein
bisschen älter war aber macht leute
sagen auch mal dass ich älter aussehen
als ich bin obwohl jetzt gar nichts es
ging einfach sein könnten schon sehr art
religion aufmachen
die muss ich habe einfach ich mache
skript gang nachdem nächstes höhe system
gefunden
ja aber lass mal beim stück mein bleiben
wo es ist seine dieses hier geht weiter
die tief und es wirklich groß da kommt
man da dieses finden ja das gold das
goldfisch mindestens holen
ich folge dir mal ein bisschen redstone
achten als reaktion das reicht für alles
ich glaube dir mal hinterher was wo bist
du hier vorne bin ich einfach gar keine
orientierung kann einfach nicht machen
nach links laufen ich auch nicht sie
werden nie wieder zurück du bist da oben
da oben mal wieder zurück zu unserer
kiste finden wir bauen uns einfach hoch
80 kiste aber wir noch gut drin da ist
unser ganzes ersten drin das und das ja
das ärgerlich aber ist was sich lenken
karotten filtern
ich habe ja dann lass doch dann der last
das zeug noch holen aber auch manch
anderes cooles zeug vincent findest du
das findest du das ja ich werde das
finden was kann ich ja weiter das stück
meinen du suchst oben auf dem zeug ja
und wenn ich gehen die koordinaten kurz
durch das kein problem
okay okay ich schon wundert sich die
melone abgebauter begegne ich jetzt mehr
monstern wahrscheinlich irgendwie eine
focus melone oder so dick ist gleich in
die melone weggenommen habe
das weiß man ja minecraft ist die kohle
noch weiter absackt und checken arbeit
unter tage eingesetzt später zurück
natürlich wunderschön
wir wissen noch gar nicht wie weit wird
eigentlich von unserer von spawn
wechseln wir sind hier unten ja locker
schon ein paar kilometer gelaufen ist
schon ein ganzes stück gelaufen dass auf
jeden fall
ich glaube das ist auch extra das ding
vom wird ein ja des todes ist es bei 0 0
ich glaube nicht dass natürlich wissen
aber ja gut alle einfach einfach zum
inventar behalten
ja aber das essen war wirklich zu viel
um das alles weg mitzunehmen
denn immer nur das essen mit jetzt ja
ich frage mich das essen mit wird man
einfach verschieden nach innen die werte
ausserhalb der kugel bis kann zwar
wieder rein
also da also kannst dann wieder sagte
rhein aber alles was also wenn du einmal
dein zeug außerhalb der kuppel verliert
dann ist vorbei ich mein was du im
inventar ist nimmst du mit ja das nimmst
du immer mit das ist ja wie bei was
passiert in der wenn du verschoben wird
und die kuppel dich theoretisch
mitnehmen müsste also hätte gerne das
nenn ich schieb dich ja nicht mehr
benutzt du in der conti sachen tragen
dass du kannst ja nee weil theoretisch
hab mir das so vorgestellt dass die
verschoben wird und dann halt irgendwie
der wand steckst du bist dann außerhalb
der mann ist ja keine riesige glaswand
ausnahme von uns herum nein aber die
kuppel weißt du bist irgendwie bewegt
werden
verstehst was ich meine ja ja und dann
dann wird wahrscheinlich wenn mir das so
vor dass zuerst verschoben bist so durch
die wende durch quasi und dass er dann
irgendeine band steckt und erstickt ok
ich mir das vorstellen keine schöne
vorstellung aber eine wunderbare
vorstellung hast du hängst service
behinderte aber wir können ja noch ein
bisschen farben also ich weiß garnicht
wird die bedingungen schon kleine also
jetzt schon nennenswert kreisliste in
chat angezeigt werden wenn die manager
wird kleiner wäre das im chat angezeigt
glaube wir können auf jeden fall ein
bisschen weiter strippen
hast du schon was gefunden ich bin immer
noch auf dem weg nach oben
hab ich denn hier wieder eine lange
keine lag männer mit katzen durch lage
nach oben geschoben aber leider leider
da fließt sowie runter da hinten
leider leider keine dir das hier ist
wahrscheinlich der beste tipp einfach
versuchen an einer position wo es nach
oben geht festzuhalten und an einmal
weiter zu gehen dann bei maximal kleinen
quergang gekommen sind haben immer noch
nicht ja das hat die sache wenn man
keine riesige youtuber ist dann hat man
nicht immer tausend twitter fragen und
kommt gar nicht hinterher sondern eher
anders
man versucht den fragen
hinterherzurennen wirklich so sachen wie
schulen so ja das sollte man auch
apropos einer seiner fans getroffen dass
andere gäste angereist und genau hier
gerade vergessen hast du denn schon fans
getroffen
ja letztens erst nicht ob ich sie
erzählt aber ich hab so trainiert im
kraftraum und gehe dann raus der
kraftvollste persona turnhalle und da
laufe ich durch die turnhalle und wer
also zurück zum auto wieder wegfahren
und er tritt also eine
handballmannschaft eine
handballmannschaft und richtig richtig
lustig auf die rufe auf einmal so escape
bist du bist nicht so wie er das wollte
auch für die 2 das zweite mal dass
überhaupt erkannt wurde im reallife also
dass ich überhaupt mal jemand kennt ja
klar das ist schon heftig und meine
meine meine kollegen haben sich übels
gefreut und ich fand es weniger lustig
natürlich war klar aber ich fand's mega
cool also ich finde es super cool ich
bin niemand der dienst stellt man leute
ihn erkennen eher im gegenteil ich finde
es super
da kann ich so meine dann kann ich
meinen abonnenten vorbei sollte drei
herzen folgt was was was von anfang
hatte ich ein halbes jahr
warum hat es zu früh
nein nein ich hab ich noch vergessen ein
hohes alter
das war irgendwie richtig schlechte idee
sowie eine richtig dumme idee war das
blöde ist desto mehr monster man in der
neuen minecraft und desto mehr kommen
echt level das levelsystem ja ach du
scheiße je mehr level man hat desto mehr
kommen nein desto mehr man in der
umgebung in einer tankstelle desto mehr
werden auftreten was zur hölle
und irgendwie ja schon lang voll mit
mops oder wie ein verhör westen höher
wird die sparrate einfach ich finde
einfach keine diaz ist jetzt auch die
richter so richtig stilvoll wenn man sie
einfach geradeaus baut aber wir müssen
einfach mal ein bisschen wie wenn wir
dies in edderitz finden dann geht's ab
dann geht's ab man müsste auch mal
schauen ob man es auf ganz normal finden
kann wie dir es so läuft bewohner haben
meldet die findest du auch keine dörfer
wälder grafik
das ist das seltenste android gibt es
geschichten von 4 bis 31 also steht
immer das ist wirklich richtig diese
hätten das seltenste materialien ganz
minecraft aber man kann sich damit halte
die dings machen die legend waffen legen
es komplett deren waffen
wir können jeden fall schon mal die
schwerter machen
ja das reicht schon mal bewahrte haavi
bräuchten hast du leder ja oder ich hab
schon rausgeworfen ja ich hab leider
rausgeworfen
wir bräuchten ledermann müssen wir
können auch mal dran denken uns über den
entscheid mit table zu machen dann so
wenig
wo bist du jetzt gerade eigentlich auf
den weg für die top immer noch ja direkt
ob ich war ja wirklich absolution ja
aber warum leider keine neuentwicklung
von oben ach du scheiße
so haben wir uns hier nur darauf
eingelassen ach du scheiße und ihr muss
mich nur eine sache anspringe nicht
gruselig zu tode
und ich finde einfach keine thias hören
das ist richtig seltsam richtig richtig
selbst an weil ich gesagt wollt die
ganze zeit hier so zieht ab aber tauchen
einfach keine tigers auf gekümmert in
die kommentare schreiben gute tipps habt
zum die us farmen aber ich habe
irgendwie gefühl diapharm es immer so
eine gerade einmal of fucking skelett
pool enchanted mit bogen so eine halb
weiß halt immer wie soll man sich hier
nicht verirren leute okay jetzt bin ich
aber wieder bei unserer besten sollte
ich alles kleiner anfang
so richtig viel eisen 6 30 eisen haben
wir können ein bisschen was brennen und
ich glaube ich brauche einfach mal kurz
und mülleimer von selbst hatten sich
fast schon von selbst gestellt diese
modelle pre das eines habe ich hoffe ich
prüft jetzt niemand rein aber da hatte
ich aber das 2
über alter einfach folien startet wieso
wird er denn das zeugnis inventars hallo
steuerung funktioniert es nicht ab auf
welche version zeigen will
ich weiß es nicht steuerung funktioniert
nicht anis behalten wir mal da kann man
das weite feld machen nachher eine frage
eine frage wie weit sind wir jetzt wie
viel zeit haben wir sind bei 15 39 folge
ist vorbei heute wir sind getrennt hier
in den höhlen
wir sind getrennt das kann ja was werden
und ohne wird es war eine richtig dumme
idee man leute haben jetzt auf jeden
fall ist sie auf reisen sind relativ
neues equipment sehen uns dann in der
nächsten folge wir vielleicht mit oder
ziemlich sicher mit pvp action weil wir
einfach den nächsten pass hat machte der
wiesn server geht bis dann leute lasst
eine fusion werden da haut rein und